foreign
as we look ahead to the Red Wave
potentially a red tsunami potentially a
big blue wall if the Democrats steal the
election there are five races that I'm
really really focused on we'll get to
all the big Senate races and everything
that people are talking about in
Pennsylvania and Georgia
the biggest race that I am watching on
Election night is New York's 17th
congressional district
for two reasons one it's legitimately a
Bellwether this is a seat that's been
held by Republicans and by democrats
everyone thinks that New Yorkers are all
big Libs but there are a lot of
conservatives there as well it's a seat
that is currently held by the head of
the D Triple C this is the Democrat
Congressional Campaign Committee Sean
Patrick Maloney and then the second
reason is that's my district that's
where I grew up that's where I first
came up in politics I have worked
multiple campaigns in this District a
winning campaign in 2010 for my friend
Nan Hayworth people said we couldn't win
it's a liberal New York and then what
happens Nan and a number of other
Republicans go ahead and win the seat
next time around
a Democrat won that seat Nan lost the
race we were all very upset the
Democrats named Sean Patrick Maloney the
man who still has that seat why did the
Democrat win redistricting so what it's
going to tell you is which way is the
country moving which way is the swing
District going to swing pretty serious
potential pickup for the Republicans and
it would be I think the first time in
history
that the head of the Democrat
Congressional Campaign Committee would
lose his seat while he's running the D
Triple C very exciting and a personal
Vendetta for me next up is the Georgia
Senate race Everybody is watching this
race it's Herschel Walker who's a legend
in Georgia running against Raphael
Warnock who's a socialist Warnock is the
incumbent though he hasn't been in the
seat for very long and you got Walker
coming in that looks really good for the
Republicans I wouldn't wouldn't rest
easy though I don't think this is the
time for complacency because there can
be Shenanigans in Georgia I know that
we're not allowed to talk about election
Shenanigans and every single election
that the Democrats run is the most
wonderful dignified totally absent any
sort of fraud sort of election ever but
that's just not the case there were
legitimate questions raised about the
way Georgia conducted its elections in
2020 if it's really a nail biter I do
fear that you could get some broken
water pipes and some absentee ballots
coming in at the very last moment the
reason that Herschel Walker should feel
somewhat confident though is the
Democrats tried their October surprise
these salacious claims that Herschel
Walker had all sorts of terrible
relations with women and he slept around
a lot there was the suggestion that he
paid for an abortion even though
Herschel is a very strong pro-life
candidate real gutter politics really
disgusting stuff and it didn't work
actually Herschel raised money after
these attacks Herschel was not really
hurt all that much in the polls and he
continues to lead in the polls down
there so this this is a pretty strong
position the same cannot quite be said
about Pennsylvania so Pennsylvania is Dr
Oz versus John Federman it's similar to
the Georgia race in that Dr Oz is
leading right now what was the big
Turning Point here it was that debate
between Dr Oz and John fetterman he is
John Federman suffered a stroke and has
brain damage and can't speak the main
problem for fetterman is not actually
the stroke he's completely out of touch
with the voters of Pennsylvania
so fetterman said his number one
priority if he had a magic wand the
first thing he would do is let murderers
out of prison which is a very far left
fantasy I guess doesn't play in
Pittsburgh especially when crime is
going up and then the other problem for
fetterman is he said I oppose fracking
and when energy costs are hitting record
highs this is not something that you
want to hear especially in Pennsylvania
even for the greatest slickest Bill
Clinton Bubba politician fastest talker
you ever heard he would have been in a
very very tough position to work around
his his terrible policy stances but then
you add on top of that that fetterman
can barely form an English sentence
right now it's no surprise after the
debate the polls all start to turn for
Dr Oz
now the problem also with Pennsylvania
is it's a corrupt state the Democrat
secretaries of state and the people who
are running the elections are not to be
trusted they do some dodgy things and
ballots are going to come in in the
middle of the night especially in
Philadelphia Philadelphia is notorious
for this forget about the 2020 election
where there were a lot of questions
raised this goes back many years before
that that would be one reason to be a
little worried some Republicans right
now are taking Solace because they say
oh there's a wonderful Supreme Court
decision that just came down in
Pennsylvania where the Pennsylvania
Supreme Court says that the Secretary of
State cannot count mail-in ballots that
do not have a date on them and a lot of
Republicans are saying oh good this is
going to help us win let's go make it
harder for the Democrats to cheat my
reaction is almost the opposite though
because when I see a decision like that
I see the Pennsylvania Supreme Court is
recognizing what I am recognizing too
which is that the Pennsylvania Democrats
want to cheat and often do cheat so the
very fact that you need this
ridiculously obvious Court decision no
you're not allowed to vote after
election day the fact that the Supreme
Court has to say that shows you how bad
the problem is in Pennsylvania polling
right now looks very good for Dr Oz but
there could be plenty of shenanigans
then the next race we got to look at
that'd be Arizona there's a good
governor's race there too but the one
I'm focused on is the Senate that would
be Blake Masters versus Mark Kelly the
reason this Race Matters in particular
beyond the questions of who's going to
control the Senate the Republicans or
the Democrats the reason the Race
Matters is actually more about the
future of the Republican party because
Blake Masters has positioned himself as
a candidate of the new right he has
thrown out all the stale platitudes of
the last 15 20 years of GOP politics he
aired a campaign ad he said I think the
2020 election was stolen I think Donald
Trump won whoa that's a that's a
shocking statement for a mainstream
candidate to say he aired a campaign ad
Blake Masters said I think that in
America a family should be able to live
on one income very conservative very
traditional you would not have heard
that kind of stuff from the GOP the
other thing that Blake Masters does very
well is that while he is a candidate of
the new right and he's representing a
lot of traditional conservative views he
also appeals to Libertarians in that
final couple of weeks of the campaign
you saw the libertarian candidate who
could have acted as a spoiler in Arizona
he drops out of the race and he endorses
Blake Masters and tells his followers to
support Masters as well it's very
impressive the way he manages to walk
that line he brings the party together
in a way that I think is putting it in a
much much smarter Direction than it
previously had been going this kind of
squishy give up the whole country give
up the whole culture just cut my
corporate taxes kind of kind of position
he's not alienating the Libertarians for
instance he's not alienating other parts
of that right-wing Coalition so I hope
he wins he probably faces the biggest
uphill challenge right now but the polls
are looking very good for him and
especially because you're in a position
now where the president is saying that
half of the country is fascist and
terrorist and and they're illegitimate
people in our political system I think
probably they're being underrepresented
in the polls for my last race that I'm
watching
I'm watching Ohio
as goes Ohio so goes the nation JD Vance
versus Tim Ryan it's a similar race to
what we're looking at in Arizona a lot
of similar Stakes here it's about who
controls the Senate Republicans are the
Democrats but it's really about who
controls the Republican party which
direction is the Republican party going
to go in is it going to just go in the
Chamber of Commerce give up the whole
culture or is it going to go in the
conserve anything at all Direction it's
we haven't even conserved the women's
bathroom at this point JD is running
very firmly on that side of things JD is
running on on hillbilly elegy he's the
author of that book that that talked
about a lot of the issues that animated
the Trump 2016 campaign
JD got the endorsement in his primary
against Josh Mandel by Donald Trump he's
running on Pro family policies he thinks
that public policy the government should
work to strengthen the family he's
spoken of the the Hungarian pro-family
policies actually now the squishy side
of the GOP hates that idea they hate the
government they just want to let the
private corporations I don't know censor
us and destroy our whole culture but the
new right the conservatives the
traditionalists the regular old
run-of-the-mill used to be a kind of
normal conservative American they say no
we've had family breakdown that has been
driven in large part by the government
politics is just how we all get along
together politics is how we live
together in a community and hopefully
flourish and so we need we need to get
rid of the policies that are destroying
the family and we need policies that are
going to strengthen it JD Vance has done
that so it just draws a very clear line
away from the loser policies of the GOP
and the conservatives of the last 20
years toward a much more coherent kind
of conservatism I think it's going to
pay off there are fewer voter fraud kind
of worries in Ohio than we've got in
other states like Pennsylvania or
Georgia so things are looking about as
good as they can heading into election
night those are the races that I am
watching obviously it's about who
controls the Senate obviously it's about
impeding the Biden agenda but it's about
more than that it's about these macro
Trends not only what do the next two
years look like or the next four years
look like went to the next 20 30 40
years look like as the conservatives
take on a new kind of a character and
and present a governing agenda that
seems a lot more popular with a lot more
people now we've got a ton more daily
wire coverage of the election you got to
tune in on Tuesday night to daily wires
election night coverage and we'll see
you there
[Music]